welcome to the greatest common devisor
or greatest common factor video so just
to be clear first of all when someone
asks you whether what's the greatest
common divisor of 12 and 8 or they asked
you what's the greatest common factor of
12 and 8 that's that's a C back there
for common I don't know I came in like
that they're asking you the same thing I
mean really a divisor is just a number
that can divide into something and a
factor well I think you that that's also
a number that can divide into something
so a divisor and a factor are kind of
the same thing so with that out of the
way let's let's figure out what is the
greatest common divisor or the greatest
common factor of 12 and 8 well what we
do is it's pretty straightforward first
we just figure out the factors of each
of the numbers so first let's write all
the factors out of the number 12 well 1
is a factor 2 goes into 12 3 goes into
12 4 goes into 12 5 does not go into 12
6 goes into 12 because 2 times 6 and
then 1 goes into and then 12 goes into
12 of course 1 times 12 so that's the
factors of 12 let's write the factors of
8 well 1 goes into 8 2 goes into 8 3
does not go into 8 4 does going to 8 and
then the last factor pairing up with the
1 is 8 so now we've written all the
factors of 12 and 8 so let's figure out
what the common factors of 12 and 8 are
well they both have the common factor of
1 and that's really not so special
pretty much every whole number or every
integer has a common factor of 1 they
both share the common factor 2 and they
both share the common factor 4 so we're
not just interested in finding a common
factor we're interested in finding the
greatest common factor so all the common
factors are 1 2 & 4 and what's the
greatest of them well well that's pretty
easy it's 4 so the greatest common
factor of 12 and 8 is 4 let me write
that down just for emphasis greatest
common factor of 12
and eight equals four and of course we
could have just as easily had said the
greatest common divisor of two of twelve
and eight equals four sometimes it does
thinks it will find Grace contraction 24
let's do another problem what is the
greatest common divisor of 25 and 20
well let's do it the same way the
factors of 25 well it's one the two
doesn't go into it three doesn't matter
4 doesn't go into five does it's
actually 5 times 5 and then 25 it's
interesting that this only has 3 factors
I was I'll leave you to think about why
this number only has three factors and
other numbers and tend to have an even
number of factors and then now we do the
factors of 20 the factors of 20 or 1 2 4
5 10 and 20 and if we just look at this
by inspection we see well they both
share one but that's nothing special but
they both have the common factor of you
got it 5 so the greatest common divisor
or greatest common factor of 25 and 20
well that equals 5 let's do another
problem what is the greatest common
factor of 5 and 12 well
factors of 5 pretty easy one in five and
that's cuz it's a prime number it has no
factors other than 1 and itself and then
the factors of 12 12 is a lot of factors
it's 1 2 3 4 6 and 12 so it really looks
like the only common factor they share
is is 1 so that was I guess in some ways
kind of disappointing so the greatest
common factor of 5
and twelve is one and I'll throw you out
so I'll throw out some terminology here
for you when two numbers have a greatest
common factor of only one they're called
relatively prime and that's that's that
kind of makes sense because a prime
number is something that only has one
and itself as a factor and two
relatively prime numbers are numbers
that only have one as their greatest
common factor hope I didn't confuse you
let's do another problem let's do the
greatest common divisor of 6 and 12 out
of 12 coming up a lot I'll try to think
of be more creative when I think of my
numbers well the greatest common divisor
of 6 and 12 lists the factors of 6 are 1
2 3 & 6 factors of 12 1 2 3 and we'll
have these memorized by now 3 4 6 and 12
well it turns out 1 is a common factor
of both 2 is also a common factor of
both 3 is a common factor of both and 6
is a common factor of both and of course
what's the greatest common factor well
it's 6 and that's interesting so in this
situation the greatest common divisor
and I apologize that I keep switching
between divisor and factor they should
the mathematics community should settle
on one of the two the greatest common
divisor of 6 and 12 equals 6 so it
actually equals one of the numbers and
that makes a lot of sense because 6
actually is divisible into 12 well
that's it for now hopefully you're ready
to do the greatest common divisor or
factor problems I think I might make
another module in the near future that
it'll give you more example problems